مع اقتراب الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب في
اوكرانيا فقدت موسكو الاف الدبابات وعشرات
الالاف من رجالها من اجل اخضاع اوكرانيا
تقول الارقام الغربيه ورغم ذلك بقي الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مترددا باستخدام
الطائرات والمروحيات للفوز بمعركه الجو
بحسب صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه في بدايه
الحرب مشاهدينا كانت الصواريخ الباليستيه
هي الطريقه الوحيده الرئيسيه التي
استخدمها بوتين في معركه الجو مع الاحتفاظ
بطائراته وطائراته الباهظه الثمن في
الاحتياط مثل مثلا المقاتله الروسيه اسيو
35 التي تبلغ تكلفتها حوالي 42 مليون
دولار تكتيكو بوتين الجوي نجح الى حد ما
تقول الصحيفه بعدما دعم صواريخ الروسيه
بالطائرات المسيره الايرانيه الرخيصه
الثمن وضرب بها البنى التحتيه الحيويه في
اوكرانيا رغم اسقاط اكياف ل 50% من هذه
الطائرات المسيره هناك مخاوف كبيره من ان
تلجا موسكو فجاه الى اغراق الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني بالقاذفات والطائرات المقاتله
والمروحيات الجويه وكذلك الصواريخ في
محاوله لايماله الحرب لصالح موسكو هنا
بحسب التايمز البريطانيه نستعرض معا
مشاهدينا القوه الجويه التي تمتلكها كل من
روسيا واوكرانيا بهذا العرض هنا لدى روسيا
41282 طائره في حين تمتلك اوكرانيا
312 طائره موسكو تمتلك
773 طائره مقاتله وكياف 99 كما تمتلك
روسيا
537 مروحيه اليوميه واوكرانيا تمتلك ثلاث
33 كما نشاهد هنا
[موسيقى]